long journey of healing for them the
teddy bears waiting to greet those
children at the hospital are a stark
reminder of the trauma these children
have been through and at such a very
young age Jill and I Jill's with me are
keeping them all in our prayers today
today today has been a product of a lot
of hard work and weeks of personal
engagement from the moment M kidnap
these people I along with my team have
worked around the clock to secure their
release we saw the first results of this
effort with the release of two American
hostages in late October followed by the
release of two Israeli hostages I've
consistently pressed for a pause in the
fighting for two reasons to accelerate
and expand humanitarian assistance going
into Gaza and two to facilitate the
release of hostages and over the past
several weeks I've spoken repeatedly
with the Amir of cutter the president
CCE of Egypt and prime minister nety of
Israel to help secure this steel to nail
it down and I want to thank all three
leaders for their personal partnership
to get this done I spoke with the m and
president Eli and the Prime Minister
Netanyahu again on Wednesday to confirm
the elements of the engagement as I said
today's release are the start of a
process we expect more hostages to be
released tomorrow and more the day after
and more the day after that over the
next few days we expect that dozens of
hostages will be returned to their
families we also remember all those who
are still being held and renew our
commitment to work for their release as
well two American women and one
four-year-old child Abigail who remains
among those missing we also will not
stop until we get these hostages brought
home and an answer to their whereabouts
I remain in personal contact with the
leaders of cter Egypt and Israel to make
sure this stays on track and every
aspect of the deal is
implemented you know uh this extended
pause in the fighting brings a critical
opportunity to deliver much needed food
medicine water and fuel to the civilians
in Gaza and we are not wasting one
single minute since my trip to Israel
last month I've been focused on
accelerating the delivery of
humanitarian assistance to Gaza in
coordination with the United Nations and
the Red Cross I just spoke of my special
Envoy for the Middle East humanitarian
issues David saterfield for an update
and I've asked him to monitor our
progress hour by hour and keep me
personally informed from the beginning
we put in place mechanisms to prevent
Hamas from diverting these supplies and
we're continuing that effort to make
sure Aid gets to the people who need it
more than 200 trucks arrived at the
Crossing Point in Egypt into Gaza today
these trucks carry food and medicine as
well as fuel fuel and cooking gas the
fuel will be used not only to power the
truck trucks delivering these
life-saving supplies but for
desalinization for water wells for
hospitals and for bakeries and hundreds
more trucks are getting in position as
well ready to enter Gaza over the coming
days to support the innocent
Palestinians who are suffering greatly
because of this war that Hamas has
Unleashed Hamas doesn't give a damn
about them we also look to the Future as
we look to the future we have to end
this cycle of violence in the Middle
East we need renew our resolve to pursue
this two-state solution where Israelis
and Palestinians can one day live side
by side in a two-state solution with
equal measure of freedom and dignity two
states for two peoples and it's more
important now than ever hamash unleash
this terrorist attack because they fear
nothing more than Israelis and
Palestinians living side by side in
peace you know to continue down the path
of Terror and violence and killing war
is to give Hamas what they seek we can't
do that so today let's continue to be
thankful for all the families who are
now and those who will soon be brought
together again I want to one once again
thank the Amir of cutter president CC of
Egypt and prime minister nanoo for their
partnership to make what we've done so
far possible and for their continued
leadership as we all keep working to
implement this deal and over the coming
days I'll remain engag with leaders
throughout the Middle East as we all
work together to build a better future
for the region a future where this kind
of violence is Unthinkable a future of
all children in the region every child
Jewish Muslim Christian Israeli
Palestinian Arab grow up knowing only
peace that's what we do we're waiting
now just a matter of I thought maybe
even soon as by the time I got here but
in the next hour or so we'll know what
the second wave of releases are and I'm
hopeful that is as as we anticipate so
thank you all for